[Music]
I'm here with one of my favorite people
in the world one of my nearest and
dearest friends for almost a decade
right oh my god I think it's been nearly
three or four years it's not true it's
been much longer than that TJ Miller
star of screen and television yeah big
screen big screen film screen little
screen and you can see me on your phone
can I rest you I would love you to roast
me
you look like pee-wee Herman's lawyer
okay I know no that's I mean that that
cut to the core no I did it did cuz I've
had a lot of legal problems master-maid
theatres quite a bit so both those
things make me feel pretty bad my
grandfather gave me this suit right as
he died and I said to me don't ever let
a man make fun of you in the suit I wore
it with pride and you will too that's
what he said Yeah right before you died
and then he wanted to tell everybody
that you are one of my greatest friends
and it was a dream of mine that you
would have your own show but I was
telling when every sirs that I don't
watch a lot of your show I die because I
get too nervous I feel like your mother
except I don't you know continually tell
you inappropriately how handsome you
look on television you know that that's
real and that's incredibly personal yes
no we both have over loving mothers I
tell that to my mother all the time I
was like mom I'm gonna write a one-man
show called I need to break up with my
mother and she's like can I come to
opening night like she's just hi can I
get tickets I'm like your CEO date for
the premiere I speak to her so so
candidly I'm like this is about my
ability to have regular relationships
with women and she's like I love your
jeans
my mother would be like it says we need
to talk about no my mother even though
you know we're making weird jokes about
her will only be thrilled that she came
up on the podcast and it I my mother
will be thrilled that you just called
your television show punk
[Laughter]
[Music]